well speaking of news we haven't been
paying enough attention to the united
states and
russia appear to be heading toward some
kind of conflict the white house has
called russia a national emergency are
we moving toward conflict and why
exactly glenn greenwald is unusually
clear-eyed on this subject he's of
course a journalist he works on sub
stack
and you ought to read them there glenn
greenwald thanks for coming on tonight
so
simple question do we appear to be
moving toward
some kind of conflict with russia and if
so why
the relationship between the us and
russia is clearly at its low point
since any time at least since the cold
war there's little doubt about that you
ask any analyst and they'll tell you
that
and the reason i think is two-fold one
is that during
russiagate in this whole hysteria that
surrounded it there was this
propaganda campaign to convince a huge
part of the population namely
liberals and democrats that russia posed
this existential threat to the united
states and they believe it to the point
where
they think that everything we can do
against russia we ought to do and if you
even stand up and question it
as we're doing now it probably means
that you're some kind of spy for the
kremlin which i'm sure what people are
going to be saying about this segment
but the other part of it is the war on
terror is winding down we're not in
iraq anymore we're coming out of
afghanistan and so the question is how
do you keep
weapons manufacturers who exert huge
amounts of influence and power in
washington
with the business where the government
keeps using taxpayer money to buy
weapons that
don't do any good for anyone remember
the person who biden tapped to run the
pentagon lloyd austin literally came
right from the board of directors of
raytheon and the answer
always can be russia if you scare enough
people to believe that russia poses a
threat to their way of life they'll
agree to keep giving more and more money
to the military budget the name of
deterring or stopping them so why
isn't since russia is a nuclear-armed
power and
part of a very powerful axis
internationally why isn't there more
discussion
about the degradation of our relations
with russia that we're moving towards
something bad why aren't we talking
about those
well it's interesting you know this is
one of those times where it's useful to
go back
a little bit in history before 2017.
we're often told
history doesn't begin until 2017 but
there was a huge bipartisan pressure
campaign on president obama
to send lethal arms to ukraine and all
you have to do is look at a map or
history of how russia was almost twice
destroyed in the 20th century
to see the crucial uh importance of
ukraine to russia but obama's point was
correct which was
it has no crucial importance to us so
why would we want to risk confrontation
with the nuclear on power over ukraine
and i think the reason why people don't
question it is because they're afraid
that if you stand up and say there's
it's not worth u.s
lives u.s treasure or any kind of u.s
interest
to protect ukraine from from moscow you
get accused of being
an apologist for the kremlin or someone
serving russian interests and that's
become a very powerful political weapon
that shapes our discourse and is
affecting all aspects of our policy
name calling is a form of social control
and a very effective one as you just
pointed out glenn greenwald
who is totally resistant to that i
appreciate you coming on
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else